First thing to notice about JPEG is:
It's not actually a file format,
although everyone talks about JPEG files.
JPEG is actually a compression method
much like the codec you would use in a video.
Umm, and
we actually use the JPEG File Interchange Format,
or JFIF as the actual wrapper that holds that compress data
So what happened was
the Joint Photographic Experts Group, which is what JPEG stands for
came along and they created this incredibly complex, specification of how you should compress image data.
Umm, very long, lots of different options
and what that means, is that basically, in practice
You couldn't possibly hope to implement all the different options.
Progressive JPEG, sequential JPEG files, different color spaces
and so no one did.
Someone came along, and said how about this JFIF format, and everyone went:
"Actually, that's much easier"
and now everyone just uses that.
And more recently, the Exif format, which has been sort of championed by the photographic industry, camera makers,
umm, has kind of joined with JFIF, and so you'll either have Exif files of JFIF files.
Or both in the same file.
"but they still have the .jpeg-"
They all have .jpeg,
and so really, when we're talking about a JPEG file,we're actually talking about a JFIF file most of the time,
but we just don't make that distinction.
JPEG compression works in a very clever way.
So first of all, it depends on the fact that we don't see color quite as well
as we do grayscale
which is something we touched upon in our video on the biofilter.
"Two greens for every blue and red."
"And that's because our eyes are more sensitive to green than they are to blue and red,"
It also deals with the fact that we don't see high-frequency changes in image intensity very well either.
So we can get rid of some of that high-frequency information.
So bits of image that change intensity very very quickly, we can kind of sorta blur out,
and those things will go away, we won't really see a difference,
certainly not if we're not zooming right in looking at individual pixels.
So, to start with we'll talk just about the color aspects of JPEG.
I have an an input image here what we want to do
is try to shrink it down as small as possible, for storage,
and then be able to extract as much as possible on the way out.
So what we first do, is we, we, the change the color space.
We transform it into the Y-cb-cr color space, which is what we spoke about in our little video on color spaces
What we're trying to do with Y-cb-cr is separate the luminosity of an image
so the intensity of each pixel, form the actual color.
After we've converted to Y-cb-cr, we down sample,
and essentially reduce the amount of color in our image
and that lets us save quite a lot of space, without actually seeing any difference in  the image quality.
We then apply a discrete cosine transform,
which is a fairly a fairly complicated mathematical technique,
which hopefully I can explain in a slightly, slightly easier to understand way.
And then we quantize it, which is the actual lossy part of the jpeg compression.
Then we encode it and that's our file.
(Brady)What does lossy mean?
So, some file formats that we encounter
like, ah, BNP and, um, PNG are losslessly compressed.
So, um essentially, it's equivalent to put them in a zip file.
You might use LZX compression or something more complicated
but, generally speaking, you take the image data. You compress it in such a way that
when you uncompress it on the other side, it's exactly the same.
I believe it's, uh, professor rels that did a video on LZX compression.
In Jpeg, the compression is almost always lossy.
You aren't guaranteed the same image when you output it as you put in
However, it will be very very close most of the time
and the advantage of lossy compression, is you get a huge amount more compression for your money.
Jpeg allows you to do, basically any color space you want to.
You could use RGB. You could use YCBCR or you could use CIE.
and because of the fact that it's totally impractical to program every single possible color space
in your own Jpeg coder or decoder,
most people just followed the JFIF standard.
Which is just YCBCR, very occasionally RGB.
So, we're going to assume, for the rest of this video, that we're talking about JFIF
which is essentially, a small subsect of the JPEG standard.
So, we take our image, which is an RGB
and we convert it into YCBCR
And what that does, is it separates out the  luminance and chrominance components.
And, as we talked about in our other video, luminance represents essentially the brightness of the image
and it's a greyscale component.
and the CB and CR represent the blueness and the redness of the image.
But, both of these values fall, after conversion in JFIF standard,
fall into the range of 0 to 255.
So the amount of data that YCBCR holds is exactly the same as the 0 to 255 RGB
One of the nice things about YCBCR, is that human eye doesnt really see chrominance very well.
It's certainly a much lower resolution than we see changes in intensity.
So, just like with TV encoding, we can massively down sample the amount of CB and CR that we see in the image.
And, most humans, unless your right up to the pixelboard, wont notice a difference.
So, to use a demonstration: This is a flower picture that I took
and this picture on the right has had the chromance component down-sampled by a factor of 10 in both directions
So, 100 overall.
There's 100 times less color in this picture, than there is in this one.
And, to my eye, they look almost exactly the same.
And that's because my eye only sees the grey scale
and a little bit of color.
If you zoom in on one of these pixels
you can see right on the edge of some of these petals
you can see slight discrepancies, where the color and they grey don't match up.
but, at a normal level of zoom
The level of zoom of your computer monitor
or the screen you're looking at
or a photograph
you're never going to see the difference.
And we've managed to save a huge amount of space
by getting rid of a huge amount of color information.
Once we decide to transform to YCBCR we have to decide how much down-sampling we can get away with.
In general, it's very comon to down-sample the color by a factor of 2 in both directions.
So essentially, you have 4 times less color.
For every 4 Y pixels, you only have 1 CBCR pixel.
You might also down-sample by a factor of 2 only in the vertical direction and keep the horizontal.
Depending on how much space you want to save.
In general, down-sampling by that much, you wont see much of a change in the image.
So, you can get away with quite a lot.
So, down-sampling is sometimes tied to the quality of the JPG that you output.
So, in some software you will say, I want it a quality of 85
and it will decide how much down-sampling that is
and how much of a compression it does later on in the stages.
In general, most software will use a down-sample of two in both directions.
So, four times less color.
But, you might find, if you choose the highest quality,
in a software, such as photoshop,
it won't down-sample at all and it will have they same resolution of color to grey-scale.
So, once we take an RGB image, we've converted it into YCBCR
and we've done whatever down-sampling we think is necessary, or that we can get away with
That's when we pass this information onto the DCT, the Discrete Cosine Transform
Which is right at the core of how JPEG compression works.
But that's for another video.
subtitled by a terry